three two one release release it's been
a long time coming two decades after
founding Virgin Galactic Sir Richard
Branson sending his first paying
customers to the edge of space
our mission Specialists have been
cleared to unstrap and enjoy the zero g
experience
Mitchell famous but three employees of
the Italian government who funded this
flight the commander on board Air Force
Colonel Walter Villa day enjoying a few
minutes of weightlessness and a moment
in history in Viva La Italia
throughout the 90-minute flight the team
conducted scientific experiments
including how certain liquids and solids
mix in microgravity Branson himself
traveled to space as a passenger two
years ago he now hopes to send one
tourist flight every month to the edge
of the atmosphere
Virgin Galactic claim a waiting list of
800 customers each paying between 200
and 350 000 pounds per ticket the
important thing with this is it's going
to make people traveling into space even
though there's going to be the rich you
need 400 000 pounds to actually do it
it's going to make it accessible to do
these suborbital flights and I think
that's important because it's going to
make it a very common place and
eventually the price will come down and
the commercialization space is probably
where the future is going to be but this
sort of extreme tourism is under the
microscope following the deaths of five
people on board Titan submersible
commercial space tourism shares many
parallels with deep sea exploration not
least the inherent risks
over the threshold that's the beginning
of the runway the SS Unity landed safely
but shares in Virgin Galactic dipped
nearly 10 on touchdown when it comes to
convincing the world that this is the
future Mission as yet not accomplished
Martha Kellner Sky News